all right so there is a bunch of stuff
going on out there with stimulus package
and everything else and we've got some
do's and some don'ts we bit kind of been
working on I need to make up like a list
of these we're gonna try to get it done
the next couple days and get it out to
you guys on the Instagram post or
something but there's some do's and
don'ts yeah let's start with you have
been laid off or furloughed you have no
income coming in yes okay do take care
of your four walls yes sir so that's
your utilities yesterday ssin that's
your food and that's your shelter right
and you know if there's a little bit of
clothing but most of you get enough
clothing shut up okay so yeah Oh shoes
still fit so um you know but food
shelter clothing transportation
utilities those are the most Sesa T's of
life do take care of that yes don't pay
extra on death yes pay to bear if you
are out of income yes do look for a
part-time job or six of them apps in the
interim
lots of people hiring in the delivery
world the grocery world the medical
world the whatever world do that yes
okay don't cash out your 401k because
you are not in foreclosure if you've
been furloughed for two weeks yes
come on Dave don't cash out your 401k
because you are not in bankruptcy if
you've been furloughed or laid off for
two weeks get a job fill up the income
take care of necessities only don't pay
extra probably don't pay anything yes if
you do mess up your credit before you go
without food there you go Dave I like
that one to skip out on a credit card
bill before you go without food
absolutely you know and so do keep your
mortgage current your rent current if
your if your mortgage company allows you
to skip a payment and everything's going
okay let's take the next group you got a
secure income yes we're gonna continue
this after the break we got to Dave you
got a secure income coming back from
this break what do you do and what do
you don't you got a small business
coming back from the break yes what do
you do and what do you don't do SBA
loans
don't for the Earth's plants forbearance
plans don't don't
unless you're broke and have no income
then talk about it after the break if
you've lost your job or you're about to
you're in a very very unstable situation
with your income not generally afraid of
the Cova cut downs the korone of our
shutdowns but you really are about to
lose a job or have lost a job or you're
furloughed okay to buy food first lights
and water second pay your mortgage or
you're in third do peak keep gas in your
car do look for an interim job with one
of the grocery chains or the delivery
folks all the pizza places are hiring
you can make some money to keep your
household running for a period of time
until that job you had comes back or you
get a new one
yeah just like if you just walked in in
an on coronavirus situation they said
we're doing layoffs you wouldn't just go
home and sit and cry you might for a
minute but then you get up and you get
after it yes sir you got a hustle and
grind right and so you do that don't
cash out your 401k unless it's to avoid
a bankruptcy or a foreclosure and
there's no way you're in a bankruptcy or
a foreclosure today because of the
coronavirus no way you are already there
and the coronavirus pushed you over the
edge maybe right but the coronavirus
shut down and associated income losses
are not old enough to have caused a
bankruptcy or foreclosure a foreclosure
folks take six months in almost every
state and usually longer and so if
you've missed
April's payment you are not in
foreclosure you're just late that's it
calm down do not cash out your 401k now
let's take another group of people and
say you are oh ok your income is stable
but you're just generally worried about
the whole coronavirus thing well welcome
the human race right right but and so
like I don't know Papo works at UPS and
Mama's a teacher yeah
those are two stable income stable
they're not you know I got an issue
though that deliveries are going on and
the teacher salaries even though they're
at home are going on yeah and they're
really not in jeopardy they're not about
to be furloughed they're not they're not
about to do a bunch of massive layoffs
those are two stable incomes your
federal employee you're a postal worker
you're a health care worker you ain't
going nowhere nowhere okay so those are
stable incomes now what are some do's
and don'ts there so do pay your bills on
time yes all of them yeah do go ahead
and continue to baby steps whatever baby
cept your own if you're getting out of
debt do go ahead and continue getting
out of debt yes don't take advantage of
some of these forbearance plans delay
your utility bills do not do that and
that's very very very frustrating Dave
I'm going to pay my bill my mortgage
payment the other day and I just read up
on a forbearance plan they're offering
and here's why I say do not do it even
if you are a little scared continue
paying bills like we said because at the
end of your forbearance plan if it's
three months all of it comes due at one
time including that month you look up
the word forbearance yes in the
dictionary google it for those of you
don't know what a dictionary is but it
does not mean forgiveness yep it means
patience yes if I have forbearance with
you it means I have patience with you
a forbear with you and I give I give you
time that's all it means and so if you
don't pay your payment this month guess
what has you still got to pay it yeah
patients are gonna pay it by this year
yes it's gonna come back so delaying it
just to say I delayed it unless you
can't pay it but it's one of the first
three things you pay and you shouldn't
be taking a job doing something so do
not get involved in all these
forbearance programs if there's any way
you can avoid it because it's gonna
catch up with you later and do not if
you're entrepreneur business owner Dave
you could talk more into this because
that's what you are do not take
advantage of these government loans that
they're calling government grants that
they're not a grant yeah they're not a
grant it is a loan with forgiveness
provisions and you read the details of
the law like I've done in the last 24
hours it'll
you're the p1 out of it so well and you
listen if you don't maintain employment
exactly like it was and they're gonna be
looking at every little thing then
you're gonna get bit later avoid this
now I'll tell you there is something you
do want to do if you're a small business
they are allowing the portion of the
payroll tax that I have to pay as the
employer to not get paid this whole year
ooh and it had and then it is paid
systematically or not over the next two
years it's delayed it's not forgiven
it's put off but it's delayed and if
that will help you and you know that's a
lot of money here with a thousand people
working on this team so we will
definitely be not paying that payroll
tax under this provision knowing that we
have to pay it next year and the next
year you make it up over the next two
years but through the end of the year
that's a lot of cash flow that will help
make sure that our employees stay
employed that we don't have to furlough
or lay somebody off by protecting that
cat that monthly cash flow do that one
yes sir do not borrow money yes from the
SBA yes churches do not borrow money
from the SBA you've the borrower is
slave to the lender when the government
comes in and after this is over and some
of these people that don't agree with
your biblical viewpoint of life are
going to come in and start telling you
you have to do this in order to get
forgiveness the Treasury Department is
sitting the regulations in place and
they take direction from Congress and
from the you and from the president and
depending on who's in the White House
after November that could get really
messy for some of you people in the
church world in particular and you do
not want to get involved in all of a
sudden you don't do something the way
they think and according to political
correctness and you think that the Bible
says opposite of that and now you're
going to find out the borrower is slave
to the lender do not take this money it
is not free money and Dave here's
another one
do not do cash advances do not do payday
lender place drove past a place
yesterday
I sure did and I was so upset and my ig
followers knew it cuz I got on there and
I I was trying to be respectful to the
company cuz I'm gonna get in trouble why
well because you my boss and I ain't
want you calling me I think you ought to
take them down you know but I mean I've
seen 13 cars out there at this
particular payday lender place and I was
frustrating for jobs do not borrow money
at 800 percent Interest don't do it
don't and that's what the payday lender
charges they're scum and they're gonna
take advantage of you stay off of that
loss unless you're sweeping the lot and
they're paying you to sweep it don't
even go in their driveway yes do not do
that stuff do not cash out your 401k
because you're afraid do not cash out
your mutual funds because you're afraid
this time next year you will be kicking
yourself Goenka yeah I jumped off a
roller coaster right in the middle of
the ride no wonder both my legs got
broke I mean my god don't do this don't
take out a lot of credit on your home
don't be borrowing money yeah I guess
this mess covered don't be borrowing
money on credit cards to cover this mess
the number of times Anthony doing crisis
counseling over these 30 years that I've
sat down with somebody they go well I
lost my job last fall and that's how I
got this forty five thousand dollars in
credit card debt and I'm like wait a
minute
how long were you out of work two months
what did you make before you got laid
off sixty thousand dollars that's five
thousand dollars a month
that's not 45 thousand and two months
that's ten thousand what's the other
thirty five thousand oh we bought some
other stuff but we justified it and
rationalized it being called it
unemployment debt and all it was was
stupid because I was stressed out
freaked out and I went to the mall to
feel better I went to the car lot to
feel better and bought a bass boat to
feel better God don't do this stuff this
is the time to be wise and calm and
deliberate and very careful steps on
these slippery rocks you're gonna fall
and bust your butt in the creek and be
wet very careful steps do not cash out
your investments do not delay payments
on these loans these student loans you
got
free interest I hear people saying delay
the payment you're just you're jumping
all over them on that I'm jumping all
over them if you still got the income
stuff coming in no go after the payments
because now you could put more payment
more money to Wars to principle yeah
might no no interest on my student loan
for six months oh that doesn't mean me
you stay in debt six more months oh it
means if you have a steady income you
attack that much harder come on now if
you're doing the four walls cool yes set
it aside we're not worried about Sallie
Mae she can star feed your kids yeah but
but if you are got a steady income bust
that thing man use this opportunity to
push through don't be skipping payments
unless you have to to eat I said this is
the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]